Тут ми зараз молотимо пшеницю.
Фермер Александер Вольтерс – німець, але живе і працює в Україні.
Це його господарство на Рівненщині - близько чотирьох тисяч гектарів землі.
Тут вирощують пшеницю, соняшник, кукурудзу…
До ангарів саме завозять зібраний урожай ріпаку.
Чорне золото! Цього року він сам дуже великий. Він дуже великий і круглий.
Цей трохи менший, але є дуже великий ріпак, він дає дуже високу олійність.
Так, Вольтерс говорить українською.
Чоловік приїхав в Україну працювати після університету, вирішив заснувати власне господарство.
Тоді ж зрозумів, що не хоче спілкуватися з людьми через перекладача. Мови навчила дружина-українка.
Я взагалі не вмію говорити російською мовою.
"Что ето время" - я взагалі не розумію. І мені важко, коли їду на Одесу.
Так, як тут люди говорять, так і я говорю.
Александер Вольтерс показує сучасну техніку, сушарку для кукурудзи, яку встановили торік.
Німець розбудовував своє господарство 14 років.
Тож 24 лютого не зміг залишити своє творіння напризволяще.
Чоловік вивіз родину в Німеччину, а сам - повернувся.
Тоді я всіх хлопців відправив додому, ми закривали це фермерське господарство на два тижні.
Потім я приїхав назад. Ну, це моя ферма!
Добрива треба сипати, ми мусимо обробляти наше поле, сіяти соняшник, кукурудзу.
Ми не можемо закрити все - і до побачення. Так не можна, так не роблять тут.
Нині на господарстві міркують, як сіяти озимі, і будують плани на майбутнє.
Я думав, що він виїде, і ми будемо тут потихеньку закруглятися.
Але супер, молодець, що залишився. І працюємо, працюємо далі. А що робити?
У центрі Києва за роботу береться ще один німець - Маркус Пойзер.
Він - керівник школи німецької мови.
На його курсах навчаються близько чотирьохсот студентів.
Нині - здебільшого онлайн. Пойзер заснував цю школу в 2017 році,
коли спонтанно вирішив з Польщі заїхати до Львова, а потім - до Києва.
Перше враження від українців - вони завжди вдячні та щирі.
Вони більш відкриті до спілкування, ніж німці.
Це мені тут і сподобалося, і саме тому я вирішив залишитися в Україні.
Побувши тут тиждень, я був приємно вражений менталітетом українців, він дуже припав мені до серця.
Німець зізнається: взимку його насторожували новини про можливе вторгнення Росії,
але він до кінця не вірив, що це станеться. 24 лютого чоловік зустрів у Києві разом із викладачами школи.
Ми зустрілися та провели ніч з 24 на 25 лютого разом.
Це була жахлива ніч, адже нам було чути вибухи, ми бачили спалахи. Тоді було дійсно страшно.
Ми вирішили залишити Київ та вирушили до села під Хмельницьким, де провели півтора-два тижні.
Потім ми все ж виїхали з України та попрямували до Польщі та Німеччини.
Маркус Пойзер зі своїми викладачами організував безкоштовні онлайн-заняття з німецької для тих,
хто шукав прихистку в Європі. Їх уже пройшли близько трьох тисяч охочих.
Коли в Києві стало спокійніше, німець без вагань повернувся.
Це мій рідний дім. Мільйони людей виїхали з України через війну, але багато хто повернувся.
Через те, що я почуваюся тут як удома, я хочу залишатися у Києві.
Я вже звик, що моє життя, мої цілі - в Україні. Ось чому я тут.
Я вірю та сподіваюся, що ще багато українців повернуться.
Пойзер мріє вивчити українську, а на запитання, хто він більше - німець чи українець, відповідає так:
Я така собі "суміш". Я трішки українець і трішки німець. Мені ближчий український менталітет.
Я можу бути типовим німцем, але бути більш "українським" - мені ближче до душі.
Тим часом на Рівненщині зерно на господарстві Александера Вольтерса вантажать на фури,
аби відправляти до Німеччини.
Фермер скаржиться, що до війни продавав усю продукцію в Україні,
але нині тут і так забагато зерна, яке складно вивезти.
Він обурюється, що Німеччина замало допомагає українцям і з експортом зерна, і зі зброєю.
Я, мабуть, уже помаленьку більше українець, ніж німець.
Я сам в шоці від того, що німці роблять.
Наш канцлер не дає нічого. Мені так шкода.
Німці нічого не вміють вирішувати, нічого не вміють давати нам.
Попри воєнні ризики й складнощі, Александер Вольтерс мріє,
аби його господарство було найуспішнішим у західному регіоні.
А для цього, переконаний німець, він має особисто залишатися тут, в Україні.